we are set to go good morning everybody
this is the new hampshire house election
law committee we are scheduled this
morning to vote on the remaining bills
that we have before the committee uh in
order to meet the deadline of crossover
because all bills passed out of the
house need to go to the senate and we
need time to do it so our deadline to do
that is indeed today
um so before we begin voting on bills
i'm going to ask that you all join me in
a pledge of allegiance
i pledge allegiance to the flag of the
united states of america and to the
republic for which it stands one nation
under god indivisible with liberty and
justice for all
thank you we have a number of bills we
will not be taking them up in order
and i apologize to the committee so
we're going to have to break it's just
that my organization for some reason did
not follow the notice and with
everything we have going on i need to
sort of keep track of what's going on so
i'm giving everybody time to
get so the first let's just go through
the first
uh three bills we're going to take up
and 1163.
in general i'm going in sequential order
that was to try and keep track of
everything that was going on
amendments
that you should have all seen
electronically by now the majority of
them you should have received over the
weekend
and some of them we have received here
in the actual public hearing
and the last one you received was of
course from your chair
yesterday
there was a change i wanted to make with
ols that of course occurred to me over
the weekend
so
with that
i'm going to turn to cac
r 15 relating to elections
this bill
had an original public hearing on
january 13th it had a public hearing on
a non-germane amendment
on february 23rd
so the committee can vote on the
non-germain amendment or the base bill
i mean at this time i'd look for a
motion on cacr15
representative mcdonald yes yes madam
chairman i would like to move the
amendment number zero seven three five h
ought to pass
is there a second
i second that motion madam chair
representative growing second set
representative mcdonald would you like
to speak to your motion yes i would
madam chairman
voter integrity continues to be a
challenge here in new hampshire as as
many of us know as all of us know
there's been a number of pieces of
legislation
introduced and
uh with with um
without success at least so far
and
a constitutional amendment would would
be another approach to this and i think
it should be followed and
pursued
thank you representative
is there any further discussion on the
amendment
we did discuss that from public hearing
representative lane
thank you madam chair
um i will not
i'm speaking to the amendment
it's not really necessary because it's
already addressed in statutes
and we feel that it adds confusion by
including the undefined term primary
residence residency
and it also makes reference to a citizen
of the state of new hampshire
which is an unusual reference and no one
and it creates confusion so
thank you
thank you any further discussion on the
motion on the floor which is
seeing none i'm going to ask the clerk
representative mcdonald yes
representative food home o'brien yes
representative sweeney yes
representative hayward yes
representative alexander
yes
representation
representative barry
yes representative growing yes
representative
yes
marcus yes
um representative chase
no
sorry that's all right
[Laughter]
okay
i'm not to say correctly massimilia
oh okay
no but no
uh representative hamer
no
representative lane no representative
freitas
represent hamlet
no
representative
madam chair yes okay
say no for me i'm sorry representative
ward no okay
so 11 to 9.
the amendment 735
that's to
cacr 15 has been adopted by the
committee
is there a further motion representative
mcdonald
yes madam chairman i would like to move
cicr 15 octopass as amended
is there a second
i second that motion madam chair
thank you does anybody wish to speak to
the motion which is
i'm not seeing any discussion so i'm
representative mcdonald yes
representative prudhomme o'brien yes
representative sweeney yes
representative hayward yes
representative
yes
representative perry
representative growing yes
representative qualy yes clerk is yes
representative alexander yes
represent
representative bergeron no
representative chase
no
representative ward no
representative
mata miller
no
representative hamer no
representatives elaine no
representative freitas no
representative hamlet no
your head
cacr
cacr 15 will be reported by the
committee as ought to pass
i apologize for the scheduling reports
will be due today
so we're going back to the old school
where we used to pass out paper at the
end of the session and no one was
allowed to leave until their report was
done
the next bill to be considered by the
committee is
64.
1064 is requiring the use of handmark
durable paper ballots in elections
it also prohibits the use of an
electronic any electronic device to
count and tally ballots there was a
public hearing on this
on january 13th
is
there a motion on 1064 representative
mcdonald yes madam chairman i'd like to
move
hb 1064 fn and expedite into legislate
is there a second
i second then
i'll give this second to
joan handle it thank you
and that's your fleeting moment of glory
for that it's not recorded anywhere else
um i'm not making light of the bill i i
just appreciated that there were more
than one second uh representative
mcdonald would you like to speak to your
motion yes i would madam chairman
uh there has been no evidence of hacking
of these machines
the windham audit was um
which were all very very familiar did
not produce any evidence of hacking uh
we you know it came down to a folding
issue that hopefully will not be
repeated by any community and especially
windham
um
if ultimately it's going to be
determined that a community does not use
the machines that should be determined
by that community and not be mandated by
the state so for that reason i move this
in expedient to legislate
does anyone else want to speak to the
motion
representative muirhead
thank you madam chair i i find uh
representative mcdonald's arguments very
persuasive and
also want to note that
machine counting under when when
procedures are followed is is often more
accurate than than a hand count and that
that needs to be remembered also in
addition to
uh just how essential they can be in
does anybody else wish to speak to the
motion
um i i am going to speak to the motion
i understand the significant concerns
that people have in regards to the
conduct of elections and by voting for
this motion i am not dismissing them
i do think we have handled the issue of
using paper ballots in other legislation
so the reality is i think the impact of
this bill is in regards to the use of
the electronic counting devices that are
currently approved by the ballot law
commission
in my opinion there are two different
avenues that addressing machines should
be taking one is the local level this
meeting was specifically scheduled for
today
to allow the communities that had had
this
item brought forward on their warrant to
vote
i understand that the communities that
voted on this as a warrant article in
their town were sb2 towns a lot of them
will be having town meetings later this
week but there is no town that voted
yesterday
that supported the elimination of
electro of the accounting devices that
are currently used no town including
windham
so i think that to require this for
every community in the state would not
be appropriate the second reason i am
concerned about the legislation coming
forward this way is that by statute we
give authority to the ballot law
commission to address the use of
machines and if there is an issue with
the machines i think the appropriate way
to address it is through the ballot law
commission in regards
to the examination and approval of any
machines used i know my community did
not vote
to get rid of the counting devices i
will say that the warren article as
presented was changed at the
deliberative session but the warren
article as presented i thought was still
clear as to what it was asking
so i am not being dismissive of people's
concerns when i vote for this but i am
being cognizant of the issue that our
municipalities have the power to
legislate this themselves and that the
ballot law commission has been tasked by
statute to address the issue for the
state
thank you
is there any further discussion
representative growing
madam chair i would like to add to that
that we're going to be addressing this
in two
bills that are coming up one of them uh
specifically addresses overvotes and
will require that any uh ballot that
contains an overvote will be kicked back
by the machine and the voter then will
place it in a separate box to be hand
counted so i think that deals with the
primary issue that we've that we've seen
with regard to the machines and
and then a second bill we're going to be
looking at
requires that on any recount that is
done on a
lower ballot race in a statewide
election
uh will also include a recount of one of
the
top of ballot races and i think that
again just adds some more
uh some checks some safety checks and
we'll deal with the issues at hand
although representative growing you're
not presuming what the outcome of any
vote might be in this committee are you
probably
is there any further discussion on the
motion which is itl 1064.
seeing none i'm going to ask the clerk
representative mcdonald yes
representative prudhomme o'brien yes
representative sweeney yes
representative hayward yes
representative alexander
yes
representative tarosian yes
representative barry yes
representative growing yes
representative quailey yes clercus yes
representative massimilia
yes representative ward yes
representative chase yes
representative hamer yes
representative lane yes representative
freitas yes representative hamlet yes
representative
yes
the vote carries 20 to zero
um
let me ask the consensus do you think
this should go on the consent or just
put it on the regular calendar
consent okay
without objection 1064 will go on
consent the next bill again trying to
proceed numerically because that's
unfortunately how your chair got
organized instead of how the notice went
is 1163.
we received an amendment in committee
public hearing of 741
from representative porter the prime
sponsor of the bill and i'm looking to
see if that was one of the ones that got
printed out
does anybody know offhand
okay
because that's it's the top one all
right um 1163
um as introduced required that ballots
containing overvotes be returned to the
voter for possible correction
uh required the number of overvoted
ballots and and under votes and that
um
there was an amendment presented that
removed the requirement to provide the
opportunity to correct over votes that
is that direct interaction with somebody
else handling the ballot
and the amendment provides that
overvoted ballots are to be hand counted
after the polls close the public hearing
on this was
in february on the 23rd
is there a motion on 1163
madam chair representative lane
i have a motion to
pass the amendment
that you just mentioned
2020-0741 h is there a second
madam chairman i second it
the motion has been seconded would you
like to speak to your motion
yes thank you
the amendment
addressed concerns that were raised in
the by the secretary of state as to the
original bill
and regarding the fact that it created
two classes of voters and so the
amendment is designed to
address the concerns that had been
raised
and i think we had a very
for me illustrative
presentation by representative
porter so
is there any further discussion
on the amendment which is now before the
committee for 1163 amendment number 741
where i'm joined i don't think i have a
copy of the amendment representative
you're going to take care of him
representative alexander
that means we can blame you for the rest
okay i have a question representative
barry so i don't even know the
the concern i raised in committee
was that
a
the machine spits out spits the ballot
back out
and we don't actually know why it spits
it out it could spit it out for a
variety of reasons
the testimony was actually that the
ballot county machine would register as
an overvote rejection
okay so it would display it over vote
rejection that's my understanding and
then it would be handed back to the
voter who would then put it into a box
there should be no reason for the person
at the box to even handle the ballot if
when they get kicked back out as a
matter of fact i was behind somebody
yesterday it go it
it comes right back to you in front of
the in front of the box okay so there
should be no reason for anybody else to
handle it so the voter would the voter
would take that and then put it in the
other box right and that's it still
doesn't address my concern of this voter
is going to be upset that
there's this they're going to be like
why is my ballot getting put into
another box and they're like well you'll
vote they're gonna say well can i fix it
and what are we gonna tell them
a voter always has the opportunity to
fix a ballot you can have up to three
spoiled ballots at any election
and everybody working the polls should
know that so how does this not create
in regards to a hand count town is
versus a machine counter correct
that's the question it's my
my number my number one and two issues
from the beginning is is
two classes of voters i i've always
opposed that in every form
um and the second one is is
you're creating
there's no it goes back to the balance
so you've either created a second class
of voter or you're creating a conflict
between the voter and whoever is this
the person standing there
reject
saying saying it to put you back you
know if i'm that voter right recently my
ballot comes back and it's over voted
i'm fixing it right which is fine i
probably like that's fine but once again
we have the two classes of voters
problems here right because people in
hand count town don't don't get that
luxury
so i'm just wondering how is this
addressing
that concern
because it doesn't it doesn't seem to be
addressing that that's why with the
secretary of state's office i ask can we
bring the diverters back because i don't
have a problem with the overvotes being
hand counted and it's fine that's the
same class of voter
but we're now creating
one voter in a machine count town gets
the opportunity to fix their ballot
and a voter in a hand count town does
not that's two classes of voters
i've i've never supported that in any
form
i've done that for college students for
everything i've said
there's one there's one voter there's a
new hampshire voter we have to try to
treat them all as equally as possible so
can somebody answer that like how does
this fix that representative bergeron
thank you madam chair
um i would note that the accu vote
tabulators
can reject the ballot for multiple
reasons it's not just the overvote
situation
if for example this coding that
distinguishes
award one ballot from a ward 2 ballot
and if everything on it is exactly the
same it doesn't matter if you try and
put award one ballot in ward 2 machine
is going to get kicked out
if there's been a cutting error and the
bar coding around the ballot wasn't cut
properly it will get kicked out if there
was baby drool on the ballot and got a
little soggy it's going to get kicked
out
or jam the machine
my point is that as long as the election
official isn't specifying why the ballot
is being kicked out in most cases they
won't be able to
um
it's it's just an automatic procedure
for the person to put it in the the side
slot or the auxiliary compartment
whatever you want to call it
so that it can be hand counted at the
end of the night
now if the voter himself or herself were
to say can i look at my ballot then
that's certainly a right that any voter
has
so
i i feel that
voters are being treated the same under
the scenario that has been created with
the amendment in the original bill i
follow-up
so that sounds fine with me what you
just described if we're not saying if
the person's saying they're saying oh
your ballot was kicked out for x y or z
if if the person's standing there just
says the machine didn't want to read
your ballot on the first pass you can
try to put it in you can put it over
there i'm fine with that but what i
don't like is somebody saying well you
know
let me look at this and figure out why
it's kicking it out right that that i
don't like um so if it's just the
if the intent of the legislator here and
i can get behind the intent if the
intent is just saying hey the machine
didn't read this for whatever reason one
of which could be an overrode if the
machine can't babies rule whatever
we're going to put it over here
that's fine because i don't think
that'll create a conflict between
the voter and that that
poll worker that vote let's call
volunteer right um
if that's what we're doing if we're if
it's as the chairman suggests it's gonna
you know flash on the screen overvote
and we're gonna hand the ballot back
well that is two classes
so what what are we doing
let me ask
i thought we talked about overvote on
the machine but is that only if it
accepted the ballot and didn't reject it
uh yes and i think mary tillman the
memory cards currently are programmed to
accept over voted uh ballots
and so even if there's an overvote the
machine will will accept it and
it just won't count for that race but
they can be programmed
to kick it out if there's an overvote
and it can i can't say it with 100
certainty but 99 percent certainty
doesn't necessarily have to display
overvote they can just say rejected
so
i don't know if that answers your your
question
but
it part of it is to do with the
programming and whether it's going to
get kicked out or not
i'm so i'm i'm totally fine with it
getting kicked out
it's the it's that second that creating
that second class of voter that i don't
like if it's if if they're just gonna if
the machine just rejects it for whatever
reason right let's not even say it's no
but it's just a rejected ballot right
it's for whatever reason it's bouncing
back one of which we are now including
is an overvote
and we're just taking that ballot and
putting it into a hand count box i'm
totally cool
not not a problem all in for that it's
if it's if if the machine is going to be
programmed to say this is an overvote
you know
then then we're going to create that
conflict right
or we're going to create two classes of
voters neither which i like so if if the
legislative intent if we're going to if
this is going to get down and you know
this is when they're looking at this in
the future if they're going to say all
right the legislative intent was not to
create two classes of voters i'm voting
for this if we are going to
inadvertently create two classes of
voters i have opposed that on everything
that we have done and i'll vote against
it so i'm just trying to figure out what
exactly we're doing if that's the intent
i'm all in but all right the chair is
going to say that she
apologizes because she might have
created more confusion as to whether the
overvote shows up on the screen but it's
my understanding that the secretary of
state's office has been very consistent
in their opposition to this bill in the
past because it does create two classes
of voters and deals with the privacy of
the voter and that they were not opposed
to this amendment because they felt it
was sufficiently addressed
so
i'm not as familiar with the programming
of the machines as i probably should be
or representative bergeron but i do know
that that was the position of the
secretary of state representative lane
thank you to address representative
barry's point i think representative
porter worked with the secretary of
state because the intent was not to
create the two classes and
she explained that it would just be put
into the box that the person wouldn't
even be wouldn't even see the ballot
hand it back and just or put it back and
put it in the auxiliary
so i is she i mean that was her
any further discussion on the amendment
on the floor
which is 7 41.
representative prudhomme o'brien
yeah i i share some of these same
concerns and but i also see what rep
porter was trying to do and i i
commend that
uh but i'm looking at the amendment here
and it says the auxiliary
shall be placed in the auxiliary
compartment by the moderator or his or
her appointee to be counted after the
polls close
but at the same time you have to explain
to the voter that they have the chance
to and it doesn't
get into this in the amendment that you
have to explain to the voter that they
have the chance to revoke if they want
to
and i think a lot of voters if they're
already confused and and
are over voting then having to explain
the overvoting situation to them
will be very
difficult and cumbersome
in the moment
of
i'm concerned about this this
representative growing
so um first of all i just want to
correct the the
sentence that you just read
representative prudhomme o'brien
just has to do with absentee ballots
that are
then placed in there by the moderator
the previous sentence says the voters
shall be instructed to place the ballot
in an axillary compartment to be hand
counted so the voters handling the
ballot
i agree with representative barry
that
the intent and i'm hearing this from
everyone that the intent of this is that
we're not creating two classes of voters
and i think
that
the voter should simply be told the
machine is not reading your vote
correctly and it's being placed in a box
in the auxiliary box to be hand counted
anything more than that is just going to
create confusion because i have to admit
madam chair that i did not know what
over voted ballots were i i thought i
did but i didn't fully understand over
voted ballots until i served on this
committee and i would dare say that 90
or 95 percent of the voters in the state
don't know what that means and if we
tried to explain that to them on
election day
further discussion representative
bergeron i would just uh
hopefully this will be this will
certainly be my last comment uh the
secretary of secretary of state
publishes about a 300 page election
procedures manual
every two years which outlines
good practices best practices
policies procedures to
put into effect the intent of law
in addition to that they run training
sessions prior to elections throughout
the state
uh so that election officials can get
updated on some of the changes both to
law and to procedures they do training
sessions at the city and town clerks
association every year at their annual
meeting
i have full confidence that the
secretary of state
will
put into effect whatever needs to be
done to ensure that the intent of
this legislation the intent of this
committee and the the
uh
understanding that the secretary of
state's office has with the bill's
sponsor to make sure that there aren't
these uh
two-tiers double-standard approaches to
counting ballots so i have full
confidence in the secretary of state in
thank you madam chair i would just
add that this bill had been proposed
last session and was tabled but had it
gone through last session we would have
any further discussion on the bill
the amendment is before the committee
representative chase
thank you madam chair and
being new here and wanting to understand
if this happened and say i put my ballot
in it spit back out would i have the
option of taking the ballot and doing a
second because you said you get up to
three
chances or would it just go right into
put it over into the other
box
representative lane
the way it was described to us during
the hearing is that it would just be
handed back to the voter and said please
put it in the auxiliary box
no mention of why it's being rejected
and i think
you address that
was that was addressed so they would not
have that opportunity unless they took
it and realized oh my god you know but
nothing that is said
by the person
handing the ballot back by whoever the
all right seeing no further discussion
i'm going to ask the clerk to call the
representative mcdonald yes
representative o'brien
no
representative hayward
yes
representative alexander yes
representative
yes
representative berry
representative growing yes
representative quality yes clerk is yes
representative bergeron yes
representative chase
yes representative ward yes
representative massimilla yes
representative hamer
yes representative lane
representative freitas yes
representative hamlet yes representative
your head yeah madam chair yes okay it's
19 to 1. the the amendment carries 19 to
one
um
the
most the bill before the committee is
now
1163 as amended by 741 is there a motion
representative lane
i would move
out to pass on
house bill 1163
is there a second second madam chairman
representative mcdonald seconds it
is there any discussion on the motion
the motion on the floor is ought to pass
as amended 1163 amendment number 741.
i'm going to ask the clerk to call the
roll
representative mcdonald yes
representative fruit humble brian no
representatives sweeney yes
representative hayward yes
representative
yes representative barry
yes
representative growing yes
representative
yes
yes sorry uh representative bergeron yes
representative
matsumila
yes
representative hamer
yes representative ward yes
representative chase yes
representative lane
yes representative freitas yes
representative hamlet yes representative
your head
1163 uh
will be
on reported to the house as ought to
pass as amended the vote was 19 to 1.
without objection i'm putting it on the
1203 is relative to
the domicile residency voter
registration and investigation of voter
verification letters and the term
resident
inhabitant
and residency this had a public hearing
on february 10th
you have an amendment
in regards to 1203 which was a probably
our lengthiest bill of the session
and the amendment number is 9 6 2 h is
there a motion on 1203 representative
growing yes madam chair i move uh to
house bill 1203.
is there a second
i'll second it
would you like to speak to your motion
yes i would madam chair uh the primary
uh function of this bill is to
modify the language in the law
that
deals with sb 3 that was passed in 2017
and that the supreme court subsequently
ruled unconstitutional
and it also restores language that
what this amendment does is retains
some of the language of sb3 that the
court did not address and did not see as
apparently did not see as problematic um
and
that language some of the the things
that were retained it it keeps in 654 2
1 and 2 the
a clear definition of temporary presence
and absence it retains language that
requires the supervisor of the checklist
to follow up on persons who have
utilized the voter affidavit to register
to vote
using available public records records
and then to refer the registrant's
information to the secretary of state if
further investigation is warranted
and it retains language that keeps the
distinction between voters who register
prior to 30 days before an election and
those who register 30 days or less
before an election but it does
some modification to that and that it
does allow
for
um
a the use of a
of an affidavit
by a
registrant who
does not have
the required documentation and can i
cannot obtain that documentation and an
example of that would be a person who's
homeless and just simply cannot come up
with that documentation to prove that he
or she is a resident so those are the
primary changes in the amendment and i
urge
the committee to support
discussion on the amendment 962 which is
on the floor representative bergeron
thank you madam chair
uh well i appreciate the uh effort that
the sponsor of the amendment has put
into this to try
and remove some of the issues which the
supreme court said
were essentially unconstitutional
including the harsh penalties that were
provided in the original senate bill 3
i would point out that the secretary of
state during his testimony on the
original bill
said that there really needed to be a
lot of work put into the language that
senate bill 3
put into law it needed to be cleaned up
and
there's still more work to be done here
for example in the supreme court
decision the court found faults with a
two-tiered registration system that's a
voter registration system where there's
a
form for everybody who registers to vote
31 days or more prior to an election in
a different form
for those who are registering to vote
within 30 days of an election
and the court pointed out that the
two-tiered registration system no longer
functions as it's no longer an affidavit
to submit within 30 days of an election
well the only difference i could see in
the amendment between the two
voter registration forms is a paragraph
that says i understand that to make the
address i have vented above from my
domicile for voting i must have an
intent to make this the one place from
which i participate in democratic
self-government and must have acted to
carry out that intent
i'm not sure what that clause must have
acted to carry out that intent really
means because there's really no
definitions as to what constitutes proof
of prior actions to have carried out
that intent
in short i i
appreciate the effort that's been put
into uh amending sections of the
statutes but i think there's still more
to be done
and i would rather see that we have an
opportunity to vet the language in this
amendment in more detail um and not pass
it on on
at this time
further discussion representative
growing
um
this is a very complicated matter i
think we all realize that there's been
many many hours hundreds of hours of
work have gone into this in the past in
sb3 and
and uh i'm sure in in drafting hb 1203
originally and now i'm looking at the
amendment
i do not claim perfection on this
amendment but i also am committed to
work with the senate
win i hope this goes forward to the
senate and we can address
i'll say i'm not sure i agree with
representative bergeron's interpretation
of the 30-day issue and what the impact
was in sb3 as compared to this amendment
i do think it's important that something
go forward
because i think we had testimony from
people at public hearing who had
obviously put a great deal of effort
into looking at the statute and
proposing something and the part of the
statute they were working on
was no longer being enforced because of
the court ruling so i think it's
important we get that out i think it's
unfortunate
that the amendment attempted to do more
than just repeal it
which made
i think for representative growing it
more difficult to go through to
determine how to put things back to
where it was before sp3
and what
might make sense to retain so
i want to thank representative growing
and while there might be some changes
that might make some sense i think for
the house at this process this amendment
is a good thing for the public
any further discussion
seeing none i'm going to ask the clerk
to call for a vote the
bill on the floor
is
representative mcdonald yes
representative o'brien yes
representative sweeney yes
representative hayward yes
representative alexander yes
representative
yes representative barry yes
representative growing yes represent
quality yes
yes
represent bergeron
no
representative chase
represent ward
no
representative massimilia no
representative hamer no
representative lane no representative
freitas no
representative hamlet no representative
your head
the amendment passes 11 to 9 on the
committee is the bill is amended is
there a motion
i'll second it
is there any further discussion
seeing none i'm going to ask the clerk
to
call the role if she's finished with the
other roll call sheet thank you go ahead
representative mcdonald yes
representative prudhomme o'brien yes
representative sweeney yes
representative hayward yes
yes
representative growing yes
representative
yes clark is yes
representative alexander yes
representative burris you're on no
representative chase no representative
ward no
representative massimilia no
representative hamer no represent lane
no represent freitas no representative
hamlet no
send him your head
madam chair
yes
11 to 9.
will go to the house floor recommended
as ought to pass
as amended
the next bill to be considered this
morning is 12 47
that is relative to
folded ballots this requires that any
political subdivision that uses
electronic ballot counting machines
if it has been folded is to be hand
counted after the close of polls
this item went to public hearing on the
13th
is there a motion
representative terezian thank you madam
chair madam chair i make a motion
of auto pass for house bill 1247.
i second that
would you like to speak to your motion
representative teresian
yes thank you madam chair
so we've heard a lot this year about um
problems with
um
folded ballots and
the possibility of them not being
counted
i i know that
we like to talk about wyndham so i'm
bringing up again that um
in in their case it ended up being that
they didn't fold the ballot correctly
but i did talk to my uh town clerk and
um
moderator and and others that have told
me that
it sometimes happens it's more likely
with a
folded ballot than
one that's not folded
so in light of that i i think this
legislation is a common sense way to
have another
way to ensure that everybody's vote
counts
and so that's why i think it's prudent
to
pass this bill to ensure that
in most cases the folded ballots are
ones that are
absentee ballots that these will be hand
counted
thank you madam chair
further discussion on the motion
representative
hamer
thank you for taking my question here
the bill requires that any ballot that's
been folded to be held hand counting
after the polls close
this bill is inviting problems
i'll be voting against this bill
holding marked ballots which are folded
is just another way for ballots to get
overlooked or misplaced at the end of
the evening
hand counting done by already overworked
election workers after the polls close
will add four to five hours to their
14-hour day
and to expect to get an accurate outcome
this seems to undermine the very
argument of election integrity
for these reasons i'll be voting against
this bill
representative bergeron thank you i
would just like to
add to the representatives comments to
try and
get the committee under this understand
the scale that we're talking about in
the november 2020 election
there were 260 000 absentee ballots cast
and under this law all of those would
have to be hand counted there were
554 000 regular election day ballots
cast so this means that theoretically
about a third of all ballots would have
to be hand counted i think that's just a
scale that's very difficult for our
election officials to have to absorb and
be responsible for so i'll be voting
against the uh
the amendment and the bill
representative derozan thank you madam
chair
2020 was a very extraordinary year and
the number of absentee ballots was was
off the charts
i'll use my town
election yesterday
we had um
out of about five well
there's five thousand registered voters
we had just under two thousand votes
cast and there was a little under 200
absentee ballots
and so in most cases in
the the percentage of absentee ballots
is a relatively small number
and
the um those ballots are already handled
uh when they come in by the nature of
the fact that mailed back in that
they're being handled we did have a
write-in candidate um that did quite
well yesterday
and
i i was
observer there and saw that the ballots
were counted um
what appeared to be accurately fairly
and quite frankly quite efficiently so
again this is a this is another way to
ensure that that we don't miss any votes
representative prude homer brian
thank you i should
talk about this since in my community
yesterday the moderator chose to hand
count all the
absentee ballots on her own even though
she was not required to do so she did it
because she felt it would
be a good idea
in light of what happened in windham
i
i saw that it increased the time by
about two to two and a half hours to
count the to get the the results
and that was not a plus needless to say
as a candidate waiting for results for
myself
but if it does make people
more confident in the elections then i
am in favor of it and we can and we can
work up to it when we see how many
absentee ballots are coming we can work
up to it as as communities and increase
any further discussion representative
hamer
that's that's towns this is city
manchester is a city and we have
over four four to five hours extra work
for our already overworked volunteers
if we do this hand counting that is if
we put the ballots aside and they don't
get lost or misplaced
i'm i'm against this thank you
representative mcdonald yes madam
chairman wouldn't it be a local option
in terms of them being able to do this
i think as representative prudhomme
o'brien indicated it is always up to the
moderator as to how to count the ballots
even if a town is using electronic
battle counting machines
it is up to the moderator to decide that
it's my understanding for example if
machines break down and they have to
hand count them that will be what the
moderator has to do
any further discussion on this
representative sweeney
this is uh going to be a rare moment for
me i i will be voting no on this
legislation
i totally understand the intent and the
drive behind it i think other
legislation that we have worked on and
have dealt with already this session uh
deals with the wyndham issue that we saw
with the folded ballots that were caused
there
uh the issue with the folds there um and
and representative o'brien your
testimony in your statement actually
put me into the column where moderators
and local election officials can already
decide to count folded ballots
separately from the machine count
i say we leave it up to those local
officials and not get in their way of
doing their job so i'll be voting no on
this motion thank you representative
thank you madam chair
that's sure they can make that a
decision but
i'll use wyndham again
they didn't know what the problem was so
if those votes are never counted and it
doesn't
this is not an anomaly detected they
won't be counted and they wouldn't have
been counted if we hadn't had an
you know
audit into that so that
again it reinforces my
any further discussion on this
seeing none i'm going to ask the clerk
representative mcdonald yes
representative prudhomme o'brien yes
representative sweeney no
representative hayward yes
representative alexander
no
representative tarosian yes
yes
representative growing
representative
yes
representative bergeron no
representative
chase
no
representative ward
representative messimilla no
representative hamer no representative
lane no reps on freitas no
representative hamlet no
representing your head
hello
the otp motion vote was 9 to 11. so the
otp motion
fails is there another motion
representative bergeron thank you madam
chair i would move to uh find the bill
in expedient to legislate
is there a second
seconded by representative ward is there
seeing none i'm going to ask the clerk
sorry
the names are all different here we go
representative mcdonald no
representative home o'brien no
representative sweeney yes
representative hayward no
representative
no
representative barry
yes
no
representative
clerk has no
sorry representative chase yes
representative ward yes
representative massa miller yes
representative hamer yes representative
lane yes representative freitas yes
yes send me your head
yes
the bill will go to the floor
uh
recommended as itl the vote being 13 to
7.
the next bill to be considered this
this is relative to electronic copies of
absentee ballots there was a public
hearing on january 19th is there a
motion
madam chair i move in expedient to
legislate
representative sweeney moves inexpedient
to legislate is there a second yes ma'am
try a second then representative berry
seconds it would one of you like to
speak to the motion
thank you madam chair unfortunately
sometimes sponsors bring forth
legislation to this body that's just not
ready for prime time
and so but more seriously
this legislation we've talked with a lot
of other pieces of legislation
and i find that we've already addressed
the intent of this legislation so
that's why i would find this an
expedient to legislate thank you
is there further discussion on the
motion the motion is to recommend 1383
as an expedient to legislate
representative bergeron thank you madam
chair i'll be supporting the motion to
find this inexpedient to legislate
in part because the secretary of state's
office notified us that they're having
vendor issues right now and being able
to generate these reports and there was
no guarantee that they're going to be
able to have that fixed in time for the
fall elections so i'll be supporting the
the motion
further discussion on the motion which
seeing none i'm going to ask the clerk
to call the role
representative mcdonald yes
representative o'brien yes
representative sweeney yes
representative hayward yes
representative alexander yes
representation yes representative barry
yes
representative growing up
yes representative quality yes
turkish yes
representative bergeron yes
representative chase yes representative
ward yes
representative massimilia yes
representative hamer yes representative
lane yes representative freitas yes
1383 will be recommended in expedient to
legislate 20 to 0 is the vote without
objection it will go on
consent the next bill to be considered
this morning is
1457.
this is relative to the chain of custody
of ballot boxes after election
public hearing on january 20th
and you should have an amendment
amendment 967
which i am having a hard time putting
okay got it
all right so there is an amendment for
consideration nine six seven is there a
motion on that amendment representative
tarosian
yes madam chair um
i make a motion of otp
on house bill 1457 with an amendment
is there a second second madam chairman
representative mcdonald second set
representative to roshan did you want to
speak to it
yes ma'am chair can i speak the
amendment now or the yes
so the bill is written
has some
you know problems uh as anybody that
read the bill probably sees
the amendment
fixes those problems
and rather than have the ballots
transported
to the secretary of state's office and
and basically stored indefinitely
uh this bill
simply uh changes that to the containers
and i'm gonna read it containers
containing ballots and absentee
balloting materials that have been
sealed after in an election according to
instructions provided by the secretary
of state shall be stored in a location
on the direction of the clerk
log
shall be maintained by the clerk
specifying the location the containers
of that location once stored the
container shall be accessible only to
individuals working under the direction
of the town clerk as required for
recounts are as necessary for the
secretary of state to verify the
container
storage when the containers are removed
to allow for destruction of ballots in
accordance with rsa 33-8 colon 3a the
destruction of the battles and destiny
balance material should be
a final entry in the log and that's what
discussion on the amendment
representative bergeron thank you madam
chair uh just for the record i believe
the amendment we're talking about is
number zero nine six seven h because i
don't think that number was cited yet
i apologize thank you that's right and
if i may i'm gonna support the amendment
actually i think it's a very good one um
i am a certified archivist i've had
considerable training in records
management and what this amendment does
basically is require that the
the clerks maintain a records
disposition log and and
good records management procedures say
if you're destroying records you should
make a note or log when it was destroyed
and what was destroyed so if at any time
someone wants to pull a record you're
not looking for something that that
probably doesn't exist anymore because
it's been disposed of so this creates
the record that the good man records
management practices uh would normally
require anyway and i think it's very
simple to uh
to comply with so i i think it's a good
amendment and i think it uh
helps put a little more integrity into
the whole process
is there any further discussion on the
amendment the amendment number thank you
representative bergeron is 967
seeing none i'm going to ask the clerk
to call the role
representative mcdonald yes
representative o'brien yes
representative sweeney yes
representative hayward yes
representative alexander yes griffin
yes representative barry
yes
representative rowan yes
representative
yes clerk is yes
representative bergeron yes
representative chase yes
representative ward yes
representative miller yes representative
hamer yes representative lane yes
griffin freitas yes representative
hamlet yes
the amendment carries 20 to zero
uh hb 1457 is now amended is there a
motion yes madam chair
make a motion to
an otp motion for house bill 1457
as amended
is there a second second madam chairman
it's been moved and seconded the motion
on the floor is 1457 otpa is there any
further discussion
seeing none i'm going to ask the clerk
representative
yes
representative mcdonald said yes
representative prudhomme o'brien yes
representative sweeney yes
representative hayward yes
representative
yes representative ferry
yes representative growing yes
representative quayley yes
clerk is yes
i don't know why you're down there
representative alexander yes
representative bergeron yes
representative chase yes representative
ward yes
representative massa miller yes
representative hamer yes representative
lane yes representative freitas yes
represent hamlet yes
represent your head yeah madam chair yes
20 to 0.
1457 will be reported to the house by
committee as ought to pass as amended
without objection it will go on the
consent calendar
our next bill this morning is 1467
requiring partial audits of additional
offices on the ballots involved in a
recount it came to public hearing on
february 2nd
the bill as proposed provides for
ballots and a recount a top office or a
top of the ticket
will be recounted
as selected by the secretary of state
and that a candidate could also
pick an office an amendment has been
proposed amendment nine five
seven is there a motion on the amendment
representative growing
yes madam chair i move out to pass on
amendment 257
madam chair i'll second that
thank you
representative growing would you like to
speak to your motion
yes madam chair uh
this bill as proposed 1467 is a is a
simple common sense
bill that um
asks
uh for recounts in the top of the ballot
races
each time there's a recount in one of
the lower ballot races typically the
state rep races which are the most
commonly recounted typically the in in
an election there are 15 to 20
state rep races that are recounted and
this bill requires that um
one or two of the upper ballot races be
recounted
with
each time that a a stat rap race state
rep races is recounted
one of the provisions of the original
bill that
was discussed in hearing and i found
troublesome was allowing the candidate
who was applying for the recount to
select any other office
involved
to be recounted as well
and
i felt and i believe this was testified
to in the hearing that this would
encourage
candidates who
probably were within the one percent
allowance to be recounted but otherwise
wouldn't ask for a recount just to ask
for recount
to be able to
ask for
a recount in an upper race so the
amendment removes that provision
it also instead of
specifying that the secretary of state
would
would specify one race
to be recounted one of the upper ballot
races to be recounted let's say for
governor or for executive council that
that would then be the race that was
recounted throughout the amendment
changes that and says that for each
subsequent recount a different one of
those upper five
races
would be
would be recounted so that if there were
recounts
there would be
three recounts of each of the upper
ballot races now
in in the last
40 or 50 years we have had very few of
any recounts in in many of these upper
ballot races and i think it is just
really good practice to have some
regular
recounts of the upper ballot races and
and it is going to be pretty random
because we never know
where the state rep races are that are
going to be recounted so i think i think
this is a is a common sense bill and i i
ask for your support for this amendment
further discussion on the amendment
representative bergeron thank you madam
chair
first let me
qualify what i'm about to say after i
i fully support some kind of audit
process here in the state of new
hampshire there are more than 40 states
in the country that have some kind of
post-election audit procedure in place
they're they're quite
different you know some have traditional
post-election audits some use something
called a risk-limiting audit
audit procedural audits post-election
audits under certain circumstances
there are a lot of different approaches
to conducting post-election audits
we had a bill before us last session
which was a little more detailed
than what's being presented today
house bill
524 and we retained that bill because
par and part of the argument for doing
so was that it was a very complex issue
there are a lot of ways to go about
conducting post-election audits and it
really need needed further studies so
that we could find the right type of
approach that would work best for new
hampshire
i am going to oppose this for the same
reasons that the committee decided to
send house bill 524
to retain it last session
but i would hope that perhaps
representatives from both parties might
put our heads together prior to the next
session and come up with a more
comprehensive detailed bill
that will get new hampshire a good
post-election audit procedure that
everybody including the secretary of
representative groen
thank you madam chair
um
this bill
does not call for an audit uh there's a
distinct difference between an audit and
a recount
this bill is very simple and and i i
neglected to say that the amendment also
uh changes the
the description in line five instead of
saying audit of additional offices it
says recount of additional offices and
the intent is that this is a simple
recount it's can be very simply done
each time that there is a recount
every single ballot is handled so at
this point the people who are recounting
are counting two races instead of one or
three races instead of one it's a very
simple bill it's not an audit it's just
a simple procedure to do a simple spot
check on the accuracy of our counts
further discussion representative lane
um thank you madam chair um did i
understand you to say that the word
audit had been changed in the amendment
to recount
yes it has but what i'm realizing is
that ols didn't relabel what it called
the new section and that won't go into
statute
oh no i i see look at line six
representative growing representative
ward was that what you were going to say
yeah
and eight as well it says audited
madam chair go ahead representative
when when i changed in line five it says
recount that had previously said audit
and i realized last night that i
neglected to change the word audit in
the in the two following references and
i
i will either
bring an amendment to the floor for this
um what i would prefer to do is deal
with this when it goes to hopefully when
it goes to the senate and ask that the
senate change those words to recount
because the intent is this is a simple
turn your mic on please
do you know madam sheriff would be
permissible to move to amend the
amendment in this
forum i think technically what we used
to do was run across the street and
actually bring the amendment over and
stand there and wait for it
um
i don't know if we can send an email
over to that effect with high priority
anybody
on
my chairman i'm happy to send the email
over right now and we can can we come
back to it at the end of this executive
session yeah why don't we if
representative barry you are quicker on
representative bergeron might i suggest
if the amendment's being drafted that
the title of the bill also be changed
so lines three
six
and eight
audit should either be removed or if
appropriate recount should be inserted
and then the title as well instead of
saying requiring partial audits right or
you should be just saying that would be
correct right
all right so representative berry thank
you very much for
contacting ols and put the little flag
on it for high priority
and i will just note to representative
bergeron's comments
um i will be asking for members who are
interested in working on an audit bill
to be doing so after crossover we have a
senate bill coming over
that provides for an audit for the 2020
election
and so i will be looking for people to
take a look at that um just given the
calendar in this subject it was not
something i could put on the plate for
the first couple of months of session
um and so i think that that is going to
have to that i will be asking for people
to address in a subcommittee when we get
all right so we're going to move on from
1467.
somebody make sure i don't forget it
please and the next bill numerically
to be considered this morning is 1470
this is requiring that all ballot
counting devices show the number of
overvotes uh for each race on the ballot
there was a public hearing on this
on february 20th
is there a motion representative
terezian madam chair
i
would like to make a motion
to find house bill 1470 fn in expediting
the legislate
is there a second second
it's been moved and seconded by
representative bergeron representative
teresian would you like to speak to your
initially upon reading this
bill i thought it was a good idea but
after learning that
overvotes don't register in the machine
although i think i heard something a
little contradictory earlier today
in this room
but for the most part
it accomplishes nothing if it if if an
overvote
doesn't show up on the tape
there's nothing you really can do with
this
further discussion on the motion
we learned there's a difference between
overvotes and blanks
representative mcdonald no oh all right
i say my gun there's no further
discussion i'm going to ask the clerk to
representative mcdonald yes
representative prudhomme o'brien yes
representative sweeney yes
representative hayward yes
representative alexander yes
representative
yes represent barry yes
yes
representative bergeron yes
representative chase yes representative
ward yes
representative massimilia yes represent
hamer yes representative elaine yes
and freitas yes representative hamlet
yes represent your head yes
the vote on hb 1470 is inexpedient to
legislate 20 to zero without objection
that will go on the consent calendar
the next bill to be considered this
morning continuing our numerical
progression
is
1473 authorizing
a forensic audit of
the november 3rd 2020 election results
in merrimack county for president
governor and united states senate races
this had a public hearing
on february 2nd
is there a motion representative
mcdonald yes madam chairman i'd like to
move this bill be sent to interim study
is there a second yes madam chair i will
second that representative hayward
seconds it uh representative mcdonald
would you like to speak to your motion
yes i wouldn't madam chairman
there's been much discussion uh in this
committee over these over this course of
this term about audits
and um
many bills we've we've considered some
we've recommended
an expedient to legislate
this one i believe has some potential
it's a much more limited limited in
scope
for example than the one we considered
and we recommended itl that would have
required a statewide audit this is a
more focused and limited one
and i think it has potential but i do
think it requires more study before we
uh we pass it
further discussion on the motion on the
floor which is interim study 1473
representative lane
thank you madam chair um
i we will be voting for interim i will
be voting for interim study um even
though
we have no idea how any of these votes
are coming no no
we just want to make that clear again
and actually there was a few moments
here this morning where that statement
really was true right so there you go
yeah sometimes i don't know
anyway
that's right
um
but we do think the bill needs i good
grief
i think the bill needs a lot of work and
i would be happy to
work on that with
either representative mcdonald or
whomever
and
we
i do note that
mir i am from mayor i represent
merrimack county and i have to say i
thought it was interesting that it was
picked because there were no fraud or
any issues brought up in any of the
towns in merrimack county and i noted
that none of the sponsors are from
merrimack county
so
i guess i would like to understand why
merrimack county was picked
when we go into interim study thank you
further discussion on the bill
the motion on the floor is interim study
on 1473. seeing no further discussion
i'm going to ask the clerk to call a
role
representative mcdonald
yes
representative o'brien yes
representative sweeney yes
hayward yes griffin
yes
represent perry
yes representative growing yes
representative
yes
representative bergeron yes
representative chase
yes representative ward
yes
representative massimila yes
representative hamer yes representative
lane
yes representative freitas yes
representative hamblet yes represent
your head yes madam chair yes
twenty two
1473 will be reported to the house
interim study and we will be adding to
the list of volunteers that apparently
came forward today
um 1485 is the next bill we are
addressing this morning this is relative
madam chair oh i'm sorry would it be
possible to put that on consent oh i'm
sorry yes that should
1473 without objection i'm going to put
when interim study gets reported
um
is relative to direct recall elections
1485. sorry
um
this bill provides a procedure for a
direct recall of any local local elected
officials serving a three-year term we
had a public hearing on this bill on
january
20th is there a motion on this bill
representative barry uh yes ma'am
chairman i would like to move 1485 as an
expedient to legislate and i would like
to speak to my motion is there a second
i'll second that
representative bergeron second set you
recognize to speak to your motion
representative barry you know i'm
chairman there's times in the
legislative process where sometimes a
sponsor brings forward a bill that's not
ready for prime time
and needs a lot of work and i think this
is one of those cases and i think the
sponsor is well intended but you know
this is just not ready so um with that i
moved to any speed legislate
is there any further discussion on the
motion
seeing none i'm going to ask the clerk
to call the roll
representative mcdonald yes
representative o'brien yes
representative sweeney yes
hayward yes representative alexander yes
representation yes representative barry
yes representative
yes represent
yes
clerk is yes
representative bergeron yes
representative chase yes representative
ward yes representative massimilia
yes
representative hamer yes representative
lane yes represent freitas yes
representative hamlet yes representative
your head
yes
oh sorry representative did you want to
say something i did just want to note
madam chair if it'd be okay that i had
actually prepared a 55-minute lecture
um in opposition to the previous bill
i'm prepared to give it if anyone would
like to listen
[Laughter]
maybe we should develop like a cle
process where we can all lecture each
other on a particular topic and pass out
certificates of the election law
committee for endurance how's that all
right so 1485 has been
voted inexpedient to legislate 20-0
without objection that will go on
consent
the next bill numerically to be
addressed this morning is 1522 1522
is requiring the use of ballots with
embedded security in relative to the
chain of custody of absentee ballots
there was a public hearing on this on
january 20th is there a motion on 1522.
yes madam chairman i'd move in expedient
to legislate is there a second i'll
second it madam chair representative
bergeron has seconded representative
mcdonald would you like to speak to your
motion yes i would madam chairman
again
all of us are concerned about election
integrity
we have different you know ways we want
to get there but we all have
concerns about that this bill at this
point in time would appear to be very
onerous to be in terms of implementation
and also in terms of
the testing and the validation
of the ballots and um for that reason i
i don't think we're there yet and i
moved and expedient to legislate
their further discussion on it
representative bergeron
um i i concur with what representative
mcdonald's said i i would just add that
my primary reason for not supporting the
bill is the decentralization of the
printing of ballots
that's a real concern the secretary of
state's office pays for the ballots
they know how many need to be ordered
based on projections of turnout uh
they're able to do the quality control
and ensure the ballots are being
printed and shipped in in a manner that
meets the needs of all towns and cities
throughout the state so i think this
would actually create more problems
than than would hopefully solve so i i
will support the motion
representative growing
thank you madam chair uh i agree with
the representative bergeron on the um
decentralization of of the purchases i
think that just introduces problems i do
want to add
that i
support the idea of having of using the
available technologies to make sure that
the ballots are printed on on secure
paper that can't be duplicated uh and i
i think that's for another time but that
was only one part of this bill and and
much of it was just simply
uh i i don't believe was
was appropriate to pass
further discussion representative
teresian thank you madam chair
i um i agree with what the las
representative just said um
i like
some of the aspects of this bill um i
don't think the technology's there yet
for embedded security but uh i hope
someday we do go to this and i hope it
sooner rather than later when the
technology is available
thank you
further discussion on the bill i just
want to make a comment on the technology
um the secretary of state's office did
reach out to a vendor in regards to
secure ballots and there was a
demonstration done that i had the
opportunity to go to
and it was really a slide presentation
in regards to what they could do
and what it was was dna in the ink
where each the ink would have encoded
synthetic dna i need to tell you that i
sat through half of the presentation
wondering how we would pick which
legislators dna we were going to put on
the ballot but then they told me it was
going to be synthetic and i was actually
a little disappointed
um
so the the ink actually has a dna put on
it and the ballot itself gets like a
infrared marking on it the polling place
would be given a special pen
that can pick up the stamp that is
placed on the ballot to verify
that the ballot was one that was issued
in accordance with the security that had
been placed on the ballot and if there
was any question on whether the ballot
was good you would then test the ink on
the ballot
the reality is is that
the test of the ink is not immediate
it is weeks
and it in fact is a pcr test similar to
what is used for covid testing and we
all know how excited and how we all
agree on that process
so
um it was interesting for the technology
that's out there and that it's available
i will tell you i also went to another
presentation that was available to
legislators
on the state-of-the-art security
uh for balloting and the reality is they
were just a
general reference to secure paper and i
just explained to you what a secure
paper methodology would be i don't think
it's workable at this point in time
and as far as the security of it what
was presented in that particular thing
was really cameras
to keep an eye on all ballots at all
times
um
and i won't get into where the cameras
are coming from or that kind of thing
and the reality is is that
for the the actual polling place
to make a determination that a
ballot presented is not appropriate at
this point to be able to do it
immediately with a hundred percent
confidence doesn't sound like it's there
so just so everybody is aware those kind
of inquiries are ongoing
in regards to what can be do done for
security
all right
i'm going to ask the clerk to call the
rule the motion on the floor is
inexpedient legislate the bill is hb
15-22
representative mcdonald yes
representative o'brien yes
representative sweeney yes
representative hayward yes
representation
yes
representative barry yes
representative rowan
yes
representative quailey yes clark is yes
representative alexander yes
representative bergeron yes
representative chase yes representative
ward yes
representative massa miller yes
representative hamer yes representative
yes
representative hamlet yes represent your
head yeah
madam chair yes
28-0
1522 will go to the house recommended to
be in found inexpedient to legislate
without objection it will go on the
consent calendar
the next bill to be considered
continuing sequentially
is 1527 this is relative to the storage
of total vote counts produced by
electronic ballot counting machines
you should have an amendment that has
been prepared by representative bergeron
two two two
is there a motion in regards to the
amendment representative bergeron thank
you madam chair i would move to amend
house bill 1527
with amendment 022h
and i'd like to speak to that motion
representative ward seconds it
representative bergeron thank you madam
chair
the the original bill would require that
the
clerks
scan the accu vote
totals tapes at the end of the night
submit them to the those scans to the
secretary of state the secretary of
state would then have to create
spreadsheet documents
itemizing all the data
and
part of the testimony was that it only
takes a few minutes
i can tell you from my experience that a
lot of
what
is done at the end of an election just
takes a few minutes
and that doesn't mean i'm not still
going to be out there delivering returns
to this
uh state police barracks uh at two or
three in the morning because there are
just so many tasks to to conclude
um i would also point out that these
tapes depending on you know whether it's
a primary or general election could be
up to three feet long maybe more
so the only way that the clerk's going
to be able to get it on their scanner is
to cut it up in pieces
and put it on their copier machine
that's usually what what the clerks use
for scanners and then i suppose they
would be subjected to criticism for
mutilating the tapes before they were
scanned
i just don't think it's necessary to go
through all this exercise in order to
make
the information that's on those tapes
available to the public if they want to
see it
currently
in the election procedure manual the
secretary of state directs
the clerics to submit a long report tape
to the secretary of state with the
return of votes so it's apparently
already being done although i can't say
that 100 of the clerks are compliant
with that
that directive appears on page 94 and 95
of the election procedures manual
so what my amendment does is codify
that directive and require that the
clerks submit a copy of the tape to the
secretary of state so now we'll know
that all these tapes will be available
in a centralized location if anybody
wants to examine them
statewide or from multiple towns it also
requires that a copy of that tape be
kept with the clerk's copy of the
official return of votes so if there was
someone that
is local and wants to see the the tape's
results uh there there are still
available they're retained
because right now it's just a working
document and there's no requirement that
the tape be retained once the official
returns are completed so i think this
amendment would address some of the
access issues that people raise during
the public hearing without creating an
unnecessary and burdensome required
requirement that involves scanning and
developing spreadsheets and putting it
all on the websites and so on and so
forth so that's the purpose of my
amendment
i'm seeing none i'm going to ask the
representative mcdonald yes
representative o'brien yes
representative sweeney yes
representative hayward yes
yes
barry
yes representative growing yes
representative
yes
yes representative alexander yes
representative bergeron yes
representative chase yes
representative ward yes
representative massa miller yes
representative hamer yes representative
lane yes representative freitas yes
represent
yes
the amendment
has been adopted 20 to zero
is there a motion
[Music]
on 1527
given that representative bergeron uh i
would move to um
that house bill 1527 be recommended out
of committee has ought to pass with
amendment and i don't think i need to
speak on that motion is there a second
representative ward seconds it
seeing none
i'm going to ask the clerk to call the
rule
the motion on the floor is otp a house
bill 1527.
representative mcdonald yes
representative o'brien yes
representative sweeney yes
chase yes representative ward yes
representative messimilla yes
representative hamer yes
representative lane yes representative
freitas yes represent hamlet
yes
represent your head
15 27 will go to the house recommended
as amended the vote was 20 to zero so
without objection
i'm going to have it placed on the
consent calendar the next bill to be
addressed is 1542.
this is relative to documentation
required to prove a voter's eligibility
to vote
this had a public hearing on january
19th
is there a motion representative hayward
yes thank you madam chair uh i move that
uh hb 1542 should be
moved in in expedient to legislate is
there a second
i second the motion madam chair
representative taurosian seconds it
representative hayward would you like to
speak to your motion yes thank you madam
chair this is a
hp 1542 is one of multiple bills that
directly or indirectly addresses voter
identification
and this bill does not function as
effectively as the others it introduces
provisional ballots and requires them to
be held separately
if counting later this will delay
results of the election unnecessarily
the intent is to eliminate the voter
affidavit completely and then introduces
an extensive administrative requirement
without a funding stream
and while policy should not
generally outweigh cost
the minor any minor benefit added is not
worth while here
it's simply a bridge too far
thank you is there any further
discussion on the motion representative
bergeron i'll be supporting the motion
um you know the secretary of state
pointed out to us it has pointed out to
us multiple times that provisional
balloting is unconstitutional under the
new hampshire constitution and further
that if we go go down that route we're
probably opening up ourselves to having
to comply with the federal uh motor
voter acts and so i'll be i'll be
supporting the motion of ito
further discussion on the motion
seeing none i'm going to ask the clerk
to call the role representative mcdonald
yes representative o'brien yes
representative sweeney yes represent
hayward yes representative alexander yes
representative
yes
representative chase yes represent ward
representative massa miller yes
representative hamer yes representative
lane yes representative freitas yes
representative hamlet yes represent your
head yeah madam chair yes
20 to 0. 1542
will be recommended to the house as an
expedia to legislate with a vote of 20
to zero
without objection it will go on consent
the next bill to be addressed is
1543 relative to the voter registration
process
this bill modifies the voter
registration process
as to forms and also
establishes the provisional ballot
system
there was an amendment presented while
we were in public hearing which was
the correction of a
typo on line 34 the public hearing was
on february 10th
is there a motion on 1543 representative
sweeney madam chair i move in expedient
to legislate on 1543. is there a second
representative hayward yes madam chair a
second dad
representative sweeney would you like to
speak to your motion very briefly thank
you madam chair i
1543 is a great example i believe of how
accessible our citizen legislature here
is in new hampshire
this bill was drafted by
volunteers and just citizens from
grafton county who propose it to their
state representatives to then introduce
in legislation so i do want to applaud
them for their involvement in getting
involved in the the process we have here
at the state house however the
legislation did reference a number of
outdated statutes
and really just not ready for prime time
and there was no
representatives seeking to to really
work on
further amendments to it to get it in
line with current statute and existing
judgments so for that reason this bill
has been expedient to legislate but i do
want to thank the citizens that brought
this forward and got involved in the
process
further discussion representative
bergeron thank you madam chair and i'll
be supporting the motion to find this
itl and again uh the bill includes
references to provisional balloting
systems and uh there's really not
allowable here in new hampshire so i'll
be supporting the motion
the motion on the floor is to recommend
1543 as an expedient to legislate i'm
going to ask the clerk to call the roll
representative mcdonald yes
representative o'brien yes
representative sweeney yes
representative hayward yes
representative alexander yes
representative
yes representative barry yep
representative growing yes
yes clerk is yes
representative bergeron yes
representative chase yes representative
ward yes
representative massimilia yes
representative hamer yes representative
lane yes representative freitas yes
yes representative
yeah madam chair yes 20-0
the vote on the inexpedient legislate
recommendation was
twenty to zero this will go on the con
the next bill to be addressed
this morning is
was a bill that proposed that any
registered voter
could sue to remove any election
official for failure to perform
you have
two
amendments in regards to this
bill
the first one two three two was
presented during the public hearing of
january 20th with an author of
representative silber
in regards to
replacing
the bill and you also have
amendment
no
no it this is not
this is not the last amendment um
the amendment most recent one i'm
looking at is 101.4 it's dated march 8th
is that the most recent yes
do we have it
i have a copy i don't know if it's
yeah there was another amendment
forwarded yesterday christina
representative bergeron you want to read
that number again
h
dated yesterday
yeah it would have been after 10 o'clock
because i found it over the weekend and
all right and representative sweeney
have you heard from ols on that
amendment yet that would be me oh no you
sent it right
all right why don't we take a 15-minute
break
you have you got it christina
okay
just just a lot just mine so will we be
voting on silver no no just like we
didn't vote on a couple of others we're
not going to vote at least i'm not going
to move silvers i'm going to move mine
but
because like we had this other one 5 20
25.
all right we are back on the record
uh this is the house election law
committee it is still march 9th
and we are on
hb 1567 we took a break to get the right
amendment
um the amendment everybody should have
at this point is
dated
yesterday's date and it is numbers one
zero one four h and it's an amendment i
prepared so i'm going to move it is
there a second
i second the motion madam chair all
right
um the motion that the the amendment
that's on the floor i'm i'm going to
speak to
um 1567
which we heard on january 20th was a
provision for
the recall of an election official
and
there was an amendment prepared by
representative silber for the bill and
and
basically what
the
proponents of the
motion were trying to do was to remove
an election officials from office who
failed to perform their duty
duties need to be followed by that are
in statute and as representative
bergeron
set forward there's a hundreds of pages
of directions as to the conduct of
elections that is expected to be
followed issued by the secretary of
state
and the proponents wanted a registered
voter who basically has a dispute as to
the performance of duty be able to bring
a suit in the superior court
that is i can say as an attorney that's
problematic on a number of fronts
um
one we all have disagreements with how
people might be doing their job
occasionally whether they we think it's
adequate or not that doesn't mean it's
necessarily something subject to a suit
and nothing is resolved quickly in
superior court so even if it was subject
to
something that might be litigated it
would not resolve in any effective or
efficient manner it all the bill also
didn't propose that if a suit is
brought the election official will cease
doing their duties until the resolution
of the issue it really didn't
solve an issue and i will say that the
courts are not great about dismissing
things when you bring them if there's
insufficient allegations
on paper in the initial filing
i can tell you motions to dismiss get
filed and basically judges say you know
we'll hear it and make a decision as to
whether the case is successful rather
than dismiss it without going forward
with an evidence so bringing suit in
superior court is nothing i would ever
wish on anybody
um however there is a frustration i have
and i think a lot of other people that
nothing seems to be done when people are
not doing their jobs and i think the
windham election is an example of that
there are officials who swore under oath
that they did certain things and they
clearly did not and that was testimony
in front of the ballot law commission
there were processes that were supposed
to be followed that clearly were not
and windham has chosen to not um even
really discuss the findings of the audit
and the voters recently
just yesterday voted to keep the
electronic ballot system and i'm
assuming the same moderator has won
re-election i'm just sort of assuming
that but i don't know based on their
action
um so when i i spoke to the attorney
general's office about the frustration
with that and they said one of the
issues in regards to bringing a formal
um suit or action against an official is
the
the issue of intent as it needs to be
currently proven in the statute
um
and so after some discussion about that
i took a look at the statute that was
proposed in this i thought turn this off
my apologies
and um so if you look at 663
666 3 relating to official misconduct
it deals with the chapter that is the
provisions for purity of elections
and
6661 has a general penalty
that relates to
unspecified
penalties are a violation and again
while a violation is technically not a
criminal offense it proceeds
in a very similar manner 666 2 deals
with what official malfeasance is
and there are
a number of standards about knowingly
doing certain things
and then 660 or fraudulently doing
anything and then 666 3 deals with
official mixed conduct with unknowingly
standard
and then
enforcement of election laws in 666 8 is
dealt with the
by the attorney general's office
so what i'm seeking to do in this
amendment is to give the attorney
general's office as the enforcer an
avenue
to address the issue of misconduct as
that does not rise to a knowing standard
that would require a finding in a court
so
what i have proposed is to add to 6663
official mixed conduct to not change the
current
provision which relates to
a knowing failure to perform
and i am adding a provision for
and in connection with that
it is
while it is the election officials
responsibility to oversee the election
the municipalities have some
responsibility i would argue in this
scheme of elections that we have
throughout the state we have local
elections
our selectmen or selectmen in the cities
are in charge of the election
they are for entire districts and
elections occur not only as they did
yesterday throughout the state as a town
meeting but they also occur
specifically there might be a village
district
or other political subdivision that has
an election throughout the state
and in discussion the question is how do
we get people's attention to the fact
that you might have people working who
are not doing what they're doing
and it's and it's the responsibility of
the community you're electing these
officials
other members of the community are
relying on you to be doing this
correctly
so the suggestion was to institute a
civil remedy
of a fine for the municipalities
because that's what's going to start to
get people's attention we think i think
people's attention is not
there and if you have a board of
selectmen who now has an attorney
general's letter that's 11 pages long
and
at the end of it
they say there have been 25 instances
where we found that your officers did
not perform in accordance with the law
in a knowing fashion and accordingly we
are finding you 250 dollars for each of
those occurrences or a thousand dollars
for one occurrence or all of them
i think that will start to get people
attention as to what's going on
i have some concerns we just passed the
provision in regards to the storage of
ballots
i want to make sure the towns pay
attention to that
if the secretary of state's office goes
to inspect where they're stored and i
specifically left a secretary of state's
exception to the access
and finds that they are not stored
properly i want to be able to get that
over to the attorney general's office to
get the attention of the municipality to
say hey
you need to deal with that and i and i
say that because there was a recount
once
where the boxes were delivered for the
recount and they forgot a box because it
was pushed under somebody's desk
it is time for our officials to start
paying attention
paragraph three of the amendment
provides
um
that there basically is a notice and
settlement provision
and paragraph four also provides that if
there is a need for restitution and
there are specific requirements for
restitution it's not just a number
pulled out of the air
um
that there can be a penalty for
restitution for example the state spent
over a hundred thousand dollars for the
wyndham audit windham has not paid a
dime
and wyndham officials continue to point
the officials at the point of point of
finger at the state saying the state did
something wrong
so
they've never denied they've continued
to they've never retracted their
statement that the boxes were not
delivered in time for the election after
the secretary of state's office produced
the receipt showing they were delivered
so this was my effort to try and put
something in statute that will allow the
attorney general as the person who is
responsible for the
ultimate enforcement of our election
laws
to
be able to have
discussions with municipalities that
actually result in a penalty that may
cause them
to take a little more control and
interest of what the procedures are so i
apologize for being long-winded but
that is why this amendment was done i
think it does go to the intent of the
original bill which is trying to deal
with
election
the conduct of elections where things
might not be going as they should be
um and with that it is open for
discussions or i'd be happy to take
questions
representative barry i don't know how
many uh questions remember chairman this
is overly necessary at this point um you
have
elected officials conducting elections
who are
to call them derelict in their duty
would be a compliment
um
it's it's reached a level of absurdity
as the chairman just said that it's
almost stranger than fiction that you
can have 25 instances where you
knowingly did your job wrong and you're
like so what
um
there's the other problem and we've
spoken this length is these town
elections are
notoriously
low turnout low interest affairs
and
you get these people they'll run for
reelection and no one will contest them
because they just don't know so there's
no other way at this point to
get people to do the job that they
signed up to do and i'm not a fan of
punishing municipalities or people
[Music]
financially but what other recourse have
they left us with at this point it's
it's malfeasance it's
it think about the time we have wasted
on this committee because wyndham
couldn't clean their machines or they
used an illegal voting machine
an unauthorized voting machine
folding machine excuse me folding
machine um
it's it's insane like this we have to do
this it's it's it's sad it has come to
representative prudhomme o'brien thank
you i i echo those those same sentiments
i was
um i came here and i asked for this
committee and i ran uh for a state
representative because of the problems
we had in derry in 2016.
and we got the same monitor moderator
elected after that so we have the
similar situation we have a new
moderator now things are better uh but
when i saw what happened in windham and
all the work that we've put into this
and then i saw the boxes as they arrived
at the recount and they were
some of them were open
the the tape was just all over the place
if it was there the the signatures may
or may not have been there it was
infuriating to say the least and then to
find out once again
the people of windham seem to
in a very dysfunctional way i'll just
say dysfunctional
they're not paying attention to it
it's it's
i i don't know what to say i have i'm
left speechless
it's so frustrating so i applaud
this amendment thank you i love it i'm
voting for it
representative terozian thank you madam
chair and one of the things that hasn't
been mentioned yet is the damage it's
done to voter integrity in this state
people have have
it's hard to get that back and so
that's another reason why there has to
be punitive measures going forward to
ensure that we
we do the job correctly and it's not
being done correctly
we solve it so that people feel
confident at the end of the day that
their vote mattered and it was done
appropriately thank you
representative bergeron thank you madam
chair
first let me say that i think this
amendment is tremendously better than
the language of the original bill
nevertheless i won't be supporting
either the amendment or the bill if this
amendment
passes
a couple of the issues i have with it is
it's not clear who can file complaints
what the process would be and who they
file them with
i understand that it's the attorney
general who's going to assess the fine
but how does the the complaint process
how is that conducted
also who ultimately determines
negligence
uh are there criteria or standards for
that i don't know or is it someone's
opinion
i i
do know that a number of the clerics had
concerns or issues with the secretary of
state's office and the attorney
general's office during the last
state general election
because they felt that they were being
confrontational rather than supportive
and and the clerks and election
officials looked to those offices for
guidance and support and interpretations
and don't always get it or don't get it
in a timely manner so i can conceive of
situations where problems occur because
the clerks never got the support or
information they needed
maybe there needs to be a law that
provides a process for removal of
election procedures election officials
and and i say that because
if there are actually election officials
out there
who don't care if they're not performing
their jobs response
effectively or responsibly
they're elected officials and they're
going to stay in office and can continue
to do that and we're not really solving
the problem
i also wonder who's going to make the
determinations in the field as to
whether or not on election day someone
is performing their
tasks responsibly
i have to say that
i know the attorney general's office
sends people out to the polling places
many of them are very experienced and
know what they're doing
but in a lot of instances they don't
i can tell you several exam examples
from my own experience
there is a checklist for example that
the ag's office uses to determine if the
polling place is set up right and one of
my wards was faulted for not having a
flag outside of the polling place
the polling place was in a school and
there was a flag and a flagpole right at
the entrance so i don't know how we
could have been faulted for not having a
flag outside of the building in another
instance we had long lines during a
presidential election and the ag's
representative told the moderator to
print out a second checklist and set up
another set of tables so they could be
operating the same books
in two locations
clearly the individual didn't understand
what the laws were
uh or even worse we had a situation when
the ag's office appointed a state rep to
serve as his representative
in
her own ward in which she had just lost
the race for moderator and she spent the
the entire day harassing the moderator
who had beater in the previous election
and when i called the ag's office to get
her out of there nothing happened
so
i you know these these are all kinds of
frustrations from the other side of the
table if you will
sometimes the clerics and the election
officials don't get the help that they
need or they feel that they're being
picked on by the ag's office
will this help bring to light some
issues perhaps i don't know
but i don't think it's going to solve
the problem that that we have with
election officials who continue to get
elected to office and don't care whether
or not they fulfill their
responsibilities properly
so unfortunately i'll be voting against
the amendment and then the bill is
amended thank you
thank you further discussion on the
i'm i'm trying to read the news
roman numeral
number two that paragraph
and it it reads to me like the public
officer
causes the county city town so the
who is negligently failed is supposed to
cause the city county and whatever to
impose the fee i'm just not quite sure i
think i know
i i think that you know this i suppose
is one of the the worst practices of
lawyers and legislators you start with
what's already on paper so read
paragraph one
right
right so we're starting with a paragraph
that i suppose one could argue is not
entirely clear
um
and then change the legal standard
with
um and then add in regards to the fact
that it is a civil penalty given that
this is an exception to the overall
level of offense is a is a violation
i don't view this as any different than
section 1 lines 10 through 12 is
currently in statute right and
i am not aware of any action formally
taken by the secretary of state or
attorney general's office
in regards to what occurs on election
day i'm familiar with the checklist i
know that the checklist comes back but
the communities are given an opportunity
to respond and then it goes through a
further process to get to the point
where the secretary of state is excuse
me the attorney general's office who's
investigating after the secretary of
state
is actually generating a letter
after doing what i think they refer to
more as a process audit when questions
are raised they go through a process
audit with communities and they do it
every election with multiple communities
we just don't hear about it
i view this as being the action after
that because that's exactly how the
statute works now the nobody is in the
polling places assessing fines or making
findings as to representative bergeron's
comment about the support
i think that goes to an underlying issue
that the legislature needs to start
addressing
which is whether the secretary of
state's office is funded appropriately
and whether we need to be doing
something differently in regards to
the resources they have to support our
elections
and i think maybe that goes with the
attorney general's office
and the secretary of state's office so
so in roman numeral two i don't disagree
but in roman numeral two
is it then the attorney general who
makes the decision or
yes because as it is now it is the
attorney general who is responsible for
enforcement so would be making the
decision so if i'm reading this right
the public officer by their actions
basically will subject the if if the ag
thinks it's negligence we'll subject the
county and city the community that right
um
not the individual right or that
where the conduct occurred to be subject
to a civil penalty okay so not required
thank you
further discussion on the amendment
seeing none i'm going to ask the clerk
representative mcdonald yes
representative o'brien yes
representative sweeney yes
representative hayward yes
representative
yes
representative barry yes representative
growing yes representative
yes
representative alexander yes
representative bergeron no
representative chase
yes
representative ward
no
representative massimila
yes
representative hamer
no
representative lane no
representative freitas
no
representative hamlet
yes
representative your head
the amendment carries 15 to 5. um
otp as amended
representative
second said is there further discussion
on the motion on the floor which is the
bill as amended
seeing none i'm going to ask the clerk
to call the rule
representative mcdonald yes
representative o'brien yes
representative sweeney yes represent
hayward
representative alexander
yes representative
yes representative perry yes
representative growing
yes
represent quali yes
representative bergeron no
representative
chase no
representative ward
no
representative hamer no
representative lane no
representative freitas
no
representative
yes
representative your head no
madam chair
yes
1567 will be recommended as otpa with a
vote of 12 to 8.
the last bill the committee has before
it today is
1467.
we will go back to that you should have
an amendment
was requiring
partial audits of
additional offices on ballots involved
in recounts there was a public hearing
on february 2nd we spoke earlier about
amendment number 957
representative growing
i move out to pass on amendment one zero
four five uh the changes from amendment
nine five seven is there a second i
second the motion matters
go ahead representative growing thank
you representatives
uh
so on lines 3
and 13
audit
is changed to recount or in case of line
13 audited to recounted that's the only
change from 957.
all right so that was the issue we
brought up after we you discussed it and
referred to it as a
recount with the audit word still in it
representative bergeron thank you madam
chair and uh with this change i'll be
supporting the amendment and then i'll
be supporting the
bill as amended
um
and i appreciate the committee for
taking the time to get the language
corrected here on our side of of the uh
the chamber rather than let it go to the
senate uh
with conflicting language that and hope
that they're going to fix it so um i i
appreciate the time that was taken to do
this and has my support
all right any further discussion on the
amendment it's on the floor it is
amendment one zero eight five four five
and i thank representative bergeron for
all right
representative wells if you can call the
role
representative mcdonald yes
representative o'brien yes
representative sweeney yes
representative hayward yes
representative alexander yes
representation yes representative barry
yes representative growing yes
representative
yes clerk is yes
representative bergeron yes
representative chase
yes representative ward yes
representative massa miller
yes
representative hamer yes representative
lane yes representative freitas yes
representative hamlet yes
the amendment
one zero four five passes
is there a motion on the underlying bill
representative growing yes madam chair i
move out to pass with amendment on hb
1467 and i do not need to speak to the
motion is there a second a second the
motion madam chair representative
trojan's second set further discussion
from anybody on the committee
seeing none i'm going to ask the clerk
representative mcdonald yes
representative o'brien yes
representative sweeney yes
representative hayward yes
representation
yes
representative barry yes representative
growing
yes represent
yes
representative alexander yes
representative bergeron
yes
representative chase yes represent ward
represent hamer
yes
representative lane
represent freitas yes
yes represent your head
madam chair yes
did
i didn't do you
i'm sorry that's some representative
messimilla yes
all right
has been voted otp as amended the vote
was 20 to 0 without objection that will
go on the consent calendar i want to
remind everybody that reports need to be
done before you leave don't pack up too
quickly everybody we have a little we
have one more thing to take care of um
so you are aware of representative
quailly i have put in charge of
receiving committee reports
so there you go um and i'm i've given
him free rein to edit haha so i will be
looking at them but get them all to him
before you leave
um but before we conclude today we've
had a great group of people here on the
last day and representative growing
would you like to make an introduction
so john what's john's last name
john mark's last name is gruen and he
goes by jack jack but jack i i had a
chance to speak to you for a little bit
why don't you come on down and sit at
this chair jack
is from oklahoma
right there perfect and he came down
with his grandfather this morning
representative muirhead you might
appreciate this he was apparently
subjected to a 45 minute discussion in
the car on the way down here
on how the legislature works
so maybe you might want to talk to him
afterwards to see what he really thought
of that whole process um and so i
thought it would be terrific that since
he was so attentive during this that if
he had any questions he wanted to ask
any of us that he would be able to so
with the committee's indulgence we're
going to take a few minutes and see if
there are any questions welcome to the
election law committee thank you very
much for coming nice um yeah so i had a
couple questions all right um
one of them was
as i was
um watching you
i realized that there are 20 people who
vote right yes
so
what happens if it's 10 to 10.
so do you know what happens if
so what happens when it's like you heard
one one vote was 15 to five so do so you
heard your grandfather this morning what
happens when a vote when there's a
winner what happens then
um
then
if it's a yes then it goes to the senate
if it's a no wait both they go to the
senate if it's
right so if there's a winner then then
everybody outside of this room gets to
vote on it and it goes to the senate
right because because we are so smart
when we recommend something everybody
goes along with it right
all right so your question is what
happens when there's 10 10 because that
means we can't agree right yeah
all right so who wants to explain a
floor debate
representative bergeron you want to give
it a shot sure since we're going to be
dealing with that pretty soon
and believe me this was an education for
me too because it's very rare that you
sent something out of committee with a
thai vote
we had a bill with the thai vote it came
10 to 10 which means that we can't
decide
so we send the bill over to the full
house of representatives and let them
decide
and what we will do is submit
let's call them reports uh one group of
ten people will give their argument and
the other group of ten people print
their argument and then we let the house
have at it and the the full membership
will debate it on the floor and they'll
take a vote and hopefully break the tie
and what other questions did you so
another one is what other kinds of
things do you discuss it sounded like
this was mostly about voting is that
just like in a particular season or
something that is sort of our life
oh really
that's what we talk about here elections
and voting if you're here on a day when
there are other meetings going on you
might find a room where all they talk
about is transportation and pavement and
cars and you might find another room
where what they talk about is
fishing
so
what what's another somebody else say
another subject matter that another
schools right we have a committee that
talks about education in schools and
energy
and
to end laws
right and money money money the
committee
you have your grandfather show you the
room where they talk about money because
you won't be surprised to learn they get
a bigger better room
because they're talking about money all
right yeah you have any other questions
representative friedas what did you want
to say
having been a school teacher
i like to explain things and this one i
explained to a lot of people that there
are 400 representatives
in the chamber
and there are 20 committees so if you do
the math there are 20 committees with 20
people on each committee
and then they get together in the
representatives chamber to where they
vote but 100 people and
i'm sure your grandfather will take you
over to see the chamber after this all
right so what other questions did you
does the senate if like they kind of are
tied up do they ever come back or like
if it was unclear do they ever come back
and ask your opinion or advice
i think this might be our open this is
our opening to talk about the senate
everybody
i think this is it
i think clerk smith be darn
um well your grandfather could probably
talk about that because he used to be a
senator but you know we have this really
sort of funny rule
where we're not supposed to talk about
the senate
it's sort of like voldemort
voldemort you don't speak their name
we don't talk about the senate because
they're like
there's only 24 of them
and and they just really think a lot
different we haven't really figured it
out but there is something at the end of
the term when we pass something like we
talked about and they have a bill that
they talked about where if we disagree
we have something what do we call that
representative growing the committee of
and that's when we get to meet with the
senate and do you know what they call
that's like a month it's like two weeks
when that happens do you know what the
people who work here call those two
weeks what
crazy time
yeah it's the crazy season they say when
committees of conference happen and the
how often
and in what quantity do people get
replaced
[Music]
you mean like on the committee
or in the election
um
like people here like
like is it like er
every time there's new people it's like
a whole new group or is it like this
person gets replaced and that person
gets replaced
we have 20 people who are specifically
assigned to this committee whether they
wanted it or not
they have to come but sometimes they
can't come representative chase maybe
you can explain to us because
representative chase
i know from another committee judiciary
but she's actually
new to election law today so maybe she
can explain how she ended up having to
come into election law today i can do
that yes as as representative
griffin said i or chair griffin i should
say no um i do come from another
committee so when somebody on a
committee cannot attend and they're
absent we do have substitutes so what
you do is you let your
leaders know that you're willing to sub
which i did
and then they'll say okay you can suffer
this person who's going to be missing
but it doesn't mean that's okay that i
can just come in and sit down it has to
be approved by the speaker of the house
to say yes i approve that you can sit in
for so and so and that's what i do so
i'm here today
to
do my duty
to help to vote because it's very very
important on our executive committee
days when we're voting on things to pass
them to the next level
that we have
the full house or the full 20 people
here so that's what i'm doing i'm a sub
today
so and another thing is
when people come in when they're new
do you
are they like already
do they know how to do this or do you
new people and people who are here all
the time
right
so our new people here today did you we
have two representatives who are new
today
represent you want to represent yourself
what committee are you usually on why
i'm usually on state and federal
relations veterans affairs committee so
you're here today for election law did
you have any idea really what we were
talking about today
okay
all right
so she came
and she really didn't understand a lot
of the details
but she knew how to vote because she
knows that there are some people that
she really trusts with their opinion of
how things work so she voted with them
sort of like all the time
not she actually yes that's true we had
some errand subs here today
there are rules of subbing just like
when there's a substitute teacher
they're supposed to follow the lesson
plan that the person worked out for the
day
and they're supposed to stick to it and
every once in a while they go off track
but we try to keep them on track and
then the rest of us who come here all
the time
we might talk about what's coming up to
see if we're all going to agree or
disagree because we try to be very
agreeable when we're in public sort of
like a family right
you try to be
you do the best you can to try to work
things out so we might have some idea
how everybody's going to vote but to be
honest and today was one of those days
you never really know till the vote's
taken
so
and another one is
um madame chair cause they won't see one
because they won't call me queen
[Laughter]
they call me chair because somebody has
to to be in charge of how things go
right it just makes things easier if
somebody sort of
and they call me madam because this is
part of parliamentary procedure and you
address people respectfully by title so
for example we have a clerk and you
would already refer to them as clerk and
because
it used to be chairman
so now we tend to just say chair they
say madam chair
and you did away with the genuflecting
right yeah
yeah it's it's it's been a big
transition but i i've been trying
representative ward did you want to add
something i would just point out that in
good good 17th century fashion she has a
bigger chair
yeah i was asking i was
i was actually going to maybe say it
because you have a big chair because you
get a fancy headrest exactly
the title comes from the object
the curator that's important
yeah there are some people here in this
room who know a lot about the history
and how things worked
so then another thing which um
my grandfather wanted to say
is
which means i'm not very important
i think you
you are certainly the
must be the smartest ones of all those
23 grandchildren
so madame
chair could have a follow-up question
please sure
mr gruen
after
watching and observing today
might you have any interest in running
for a political office someday
but it does seem pretty neat and it
it was actually much different than i
thought it would be i kind of thought it
would be like
like everyone like signs on papers and
like one thing takes like a whole day
but you would go through one thing in
like
five minutes yeah
sometimes it was just a little
interesting because i think it they
would take longer and you'd also sign
off and make sure everything was right
well there's a lot of work that needs to
be done now so there will be people
running around with papers to sign off
so it can all go in the report for the
400 people to vote on but you're right
we we as a group try to get through
things as as well as we can and as
quickly as we can
anything else
well i want to thank you very much for
coming those were terrific questions we
are very excited that you came today
and
jack why don't you can turn off your mic
you can press the button so the red and
i brought these chocolates for the
committee so why don't you open the
chocolates you get to pick the first one
and you can pass them out go around and
offer everybody a committee all right
so
thank you everybody we will see you
tomorrow in session committee reports
you